this may look like a typical
construction site but there's more here
than meets the eye these are all former
shipping containers a company called
containers Kenya restores and sells them
some are repaired and sold directly
others are modified and converted into
apartments offices or small stores the
best selling product right now and which
has remained the the biggest part of
business is the plain containers once
that and the ones that are not
fabricated because the need is growing
some clients wants to go and convert
them themselves
but the fabrication departments are
really huge in shops and offices come
through second in terms of revenue per
month
bhaiya in Kenya old containers are often
discarded and left to rust so to prevent
that container Kenya buys them directly
from shipping companies andrey utilizes
them that way nothing is wasted the
company was founded in 2010 and employs
100 people interior designer grace
Ateneo is working on an office design
for the managing director of a company
the unit will cost about 70 200 euros
that's about a quarter of what it would
cost to produce the same size building
in stone what what I'm leasing is an
open space and I need an office right
and constructing an office is too
expensive so in terms of cost efficiency
and also outlook a container that is
fabricated would work particularly well
for what I want to do the containers
here were used only for foodstuffs or
similarly non-toxic goods the initial
stage of a conversion is the most
challenging cutting through the thick
metal to create doors and windows once
that's done the rest of the process is
relatively quick in a couple of weeks
the workers have created habitable rooms
complete with insulation electricity and
interior walls ready to paint
these greater need from the region we've
realized you are getting a lot of orders
from Rhonda for example Uganda Tanzania
so I think the future of the business is
taking there the business towards there
the region in Nairobi there are many
converted containers already in use this
study hall on a local college campus is
one of them the low cost is a key
selling point but customers also know
that they're doing something good for
the environment maybe now that you are
talking about it I'm getting to like the
idea the fact that I it's you know it's
a some recycled material maybe that
could have been rotting away in our yard
and we have sown some pretty good use
for it and we're happy to have the extra
space without necessarily spending so
much money an energy company uses this
container as an annex for additional
office space it offers enough room for
about three to four employees they say
it's quite a pleasant environment to
work in you'll find that you'll sweat
value in that Stern building but when
you walk in there it's all cool and
comfortable there so insulation is one
thing that is really an advantage second
would be the fitting you know have to
involve so much work labor and while
you're doing say wiring you can also
spot small containers on the streets of
Nairobi these environmentally friendly
structures are now a part of everyday
life here